[Music]
hey
good afternoon hey how can we help
hey um well uh um
i just want to ask some questions i
guess the advice is how to move on
i have financial issues uh we had a baby
last year
and then in december we decided to my
wife not to work to dedicate to the baby
because
um the daycare was basically almost half
a little bit more than half of her
salary so she wants to dedicate the
debate
and then suddenly uh we found out that
we were pregnant again
so now we have a newborn and she got
sick and then i got into debt
with paying medical bills and everything
else
so now i'm at the point that uh depths
are basically not letting me sleep
and uh i'm trying to see uh plan advice
need to do that to file for bankruptcy
and um
38. how much medical debt do you have
um well the majority of them are paid by
my credit card
so i have approximately 60 000 dollars
in
credit card debt okay and how much in
medical bills other than the credit
cards
uh i think right now we're at just like
three thousand recently for for the best
much deal on your cars
i'm sorry how much do you owe on your
cars
on my cards cars your vehicles oh car
we only have you only have one car what
do you owe
we all like 16 000 okay and what do you
make sure
it's pretty good yeah i guessed what do
you make
um like 58 a year okay
how much is your rent uh we bought a
house
when we moved here we rented first and
then bought the house since it was
cheaper than actually
yeah right um okay and so so
uh how much is your house payment
uh 1300 including the the what's it
called the
the insurance and and actually uh
yeah okay all right
okay um you're not bankrupt
you're in a mess but you're not bankrupt
you're overwhelmed and you're scared and
i don't blame you
which makes you a good man you're
worried about how to feed your babies
and this thing's this thing's got it
this thing's got its foot on your neck
i've been there i know how it feels and
i can hear it in your voice you're going
to be okay
we just have to develop a better plan
than the one you've had
okay are you willing to do some things
that are hard
to clean up the mess and not have to
file bankruptcy
yeah if they work it's going to be
really hard
okay what do you do for a living
um i do customer service basically right
now with the pandemic i'm working from
home
you do what customer service questions
okay so you're working how many hours 40
yeah okay 40 44 sometimes over time but
i don't get paid for over time
yeah well you don't work anymore
overtime you're broke right now you're
picking up an extra job in your overtime
lots of extra jobs six of them you're
going to be working
a lot and by the way that's going to
help your sleep because you're going to
be really tired
okay i want you working like five six
extra jobs i don't know what they are
but i want to get your income up
dramatically i'm not sure you have to
sell the car but you probably do
you shouldn't have bought the car you're
broke but it's
it's not it's not the one thing that's
going to save you and please don't tell
me how smart it was under any
circumstances
and don't tell me you have to have a 16
dollar car when you have sixty thousand
dollars in credit card debt
and you have two babies and you call me
about filing bankruptcy don't even let
that come out of your mouth
okay now if you'll go do the stuff i'm
gonna teach you
i can completely help you turn this
around and i'm gonna put you through
ramsey plus
a year's worth of teaching and you're
going to go through financial peace
university with your wife
and you're going to work extra and
you're going to live on beans and rice
rice and beans
and you're going to be sleeping well at
night i'm going to show you how
you hold on kelly will pick up and we'll
help you walk through this